Hello, my name is Kent C. Dods and I
teach people how to build excellent user
experiences wherever they are. I've
taught people how to build excellent
user experiences on the web. And now,
guess what? We're all moving over to AI
because that's where our users are
going. And so now I teach people how to
build excellent user experiences with
epicai.pro as my course platform. Go
take a look at it. Today I want to talk
with you about how user interaction is
changing, how model context protocol and
things like it are helping make that
change possible and what your role in
this is as a product developer or as
somebody who's trying to reach users
where they want to be and where they
want to be is inside of AI assistance.
So let's talk about that. My talk is
letting AI inter interface with your app
with MCPS or model context protocol
services. Uh and normally when I start
my talk I actually invite people to
stand up because or at least get their
body moving because our bodies need
blood to flow for our brain to operate
properly. Um this is kind of an awkward
thing to do in a remote setting. So
we're not going to do that. But if
you've been just sitting around for a
while, I invite you to move your body.
Stand up if you can and get blood flow
because your brain does need that. So,
make sure you're taking care of your
body. All right, so let's just get right
into it. I'm going to show you a video
of Tony Stark interacting with his AI
assistant, Jarvis. So, if you're not
familiar with Tony Stark, he's Iron Man.
And um this is from one of the Iron Man
movies. Um, as we're watching this, I
want you to consider what are the things
that Tony is having his AI assistant
Jarvis do that we are not able to do
with the technology that we have right
now and then we'll talk about it once
the video is done. Here we go.
I've compiled a Mandarin database for
you, sir, drawn from SHIELD, FBI, and
CIA
intercepts. Initiating virtual crime
scene reconstruction.
Okay, what do we got here? Close. The
heat from the blast was in excess of
3,000° C. Any subjects within 12.5 yd
were vaporized instantly. No bomb parts
found in a 3m radius of the Chinese
theater. No, sir.
Any military victims? Not according to
public records, sir. Bring up the
thermogenic signatures again. Factor in
3,000°. The Oracle Cloud has completed
analysis.
accessing satellites and plotting the
last 12 months of thermogenic
occurrences. Now,
take away everywhere that there's been a
Mandarin attack.
[Music]
That's two military guys.
Ever been to Tennessee, Jarvis? Creating
a flight plan for Tennessee.
All right. Well, that's pretty cool.
Well, I would I would like to have a
Jarvis like that that can help me. Can
you imagine Tony doing all of that
research and everything without an AI
assistant? Uh, it would take longer.
Let's just put it that way. So, what did
Jarvis do? Compiled database, generated
UI on demand, access public records,
brought up thermogenic signatures. I I
think I know what that is. Uh, and Tony
said, "Take away everywhere there's been
a Mandroid tag." So, joins across uh
different data sets. Uh, showed related
news articles. uh created a flight plan
for Tennessee and answered the doorbell
or at least showed Tony um who was at
the door with like all their you know
don't go to Tony's house if if you want
your privacy but uh yeah so this is
really exciting uh exciting stuff that
to think that like we could maybe have
some of this and so the question is can
we like what what did Jarvis do that we
can't do okay so there were actually a
couple of things it's not just nothing
um We probably uh couldn't uh create a
database based off of field FBI and and
CIA and uh shield database stuff but not
for technical reasons and the
holographic stuff I think we're we're
still working out. U but generating UI
we absolutely can do that and people do
that all the time. Uh so we have the
technology to do this stuff. So my
question is why don't we each have our
own Jarvis already like what what's
stopping us? And the the interesting
thing is that we've actually tried this.
We've been trying this forever and it's
just not it's not quite there. And so
why is it not quite there? What's what's
holding us back from being able to have
Jarvis? Like isn't that just the most
amazing experience? And and Jarvis isn't
just like a like something that you talk
with. You know, if you're in the office
with a bunch of other other people, you
probably don't want to have a talking
interface. It's also like he uses uh
typing and he also uses gestures and and
everything too and he uh generates
dynamic UIs and then he can interact
with those as well. So like it's a
really really awesome user experience.
So why don't we have a Jarvis even
though we've been working on it? What
what is holding these different
assistants back? And the answer is
integrations. It's just really really
hard to build all the integrations for
all the possible things. Here are a
bunch of logos for things that you might
recognize. some things that you don't.
Some are technical, some are like normal
people things. And I want to have a
robot that can interface with all of
them. And like here's the the real
kicker. I want to have a robot that
interfaces with everything. And the uh
challenge of building an integration for
every one of those things just means
that Google is not going to build an
integration for your local city's
government website for reserving
pavilions at the park. And I want that.
I want my robot to be able to do all of
those things. And if it can't do
everything, then why spend the time
wiring everything up together so that it
can do some things? And there are some
activities that we take or some
activities that we do, some things that
we do that don't really
um like don't make it worth it to spend
all the time wiring things up. Like we
just don't do it enough. But it would be
really cool if there was some standard
mechanism for my AI assistant to
interface with something that I've never
used before and I won't ever use again,
but I don't want to have to like click
around the website and figure it out. I
want my LLM to figure that out. And that
is what model context protocol enables
for us is a standard mechanism whereby
our AI assistants can communicate with
these uh various uh tools and services.
So let's talk a little bit about the
history and architecture of MCP model
context protocol and and just like tool
calling and that sort of thing in
general. So phase one about 3 years ago
chat GPT comes out and uh this is a
really really exciting time because it
answers our questions. It can like we
can say like tell it something and ask
it something and it can answer the
questions and maybe the answer isn't
always right because it's not
intelligent. is just generating tokens.
But like lots of the times it is and
it's gotten way better. And so this is
really exciting. And what made it so
pivotal is the fact not not the fact
that we had an LLM. We've had LLMs for a
long time. What made ChatGpt so awesome
is the host application layer around the
LLM. Chat GPT itself. not the LLM, but
the application around it that brought a
good user experience to interfacing with
an LLM. And then once that happened, a
lot of investment went into LLMs and
they got better, better, and better and
better, much faster because we started
to see a lot of value. The problem was
that you would have to provide the
context yourself. You copy paste your
code and say, "Hey, what's wrong with
this? Please refactor it, whatever." and
then you'd have to copy and paste its
result back into your codebase and then
you find out it wasn't working for uh
some other reason. Um but you there was
a lot of context like manual context
bring it in in the form of text and then
we added images but uh having to
manually bring in that stuff and then
manually take it out and then of course
you've got your context window and all
that stuff. So it it couldn't do
anything. it could answer questions but
like couldn't do anything and managing
context ourselves was kind of a pain. So
then we get into phase two where the
host application is like hey I'm like
regular code I I interface with this LLM
I could tell the LLM hey I need you to
let me know if you need more context and
I can go get it for you. So now we have
search engines and hey if they want to
schedule a time to meet with somebody I
have a a calendar integration and uh oh
if you want to summarize your Slack
messages or your notifications or
something I have a Slack integration
whatever. So the host application is now
enabling it to do stuff. I can tell it
hey do this thing and now it will do
that thing. And uh the the problem here
is that you're kind of limited with the
the things that it can do and also the
sources where it can get its um its
context. You're limited by the uh
developers time uh at OpenAI or
Anthropic. How much time do they have to
dedicate to building out these
integrations? And this is really the
same problem that we have with our
existing assistants and the existing
efforts that we've put into building
integrations with all these different
services. You're not going to convince
OpenAI or anthropic developers to build
an integration for your city government
website or anything like that. That's
just not going to work. And granted,
OpenAI has their uh own GPT plug-in
system, but it's proprietary. And so
it's uh difficult even though chat GPT
has a lot of uh buyin from the users
that you have um it's difficult to
justify building something special for
chat GPT and then something special for
anthropic and then something something
special for Google and whatever. Uh it'd
be much better if we had some like
standard mechanism. So yes, it can do
stuff and and for a lot of people who
couldn't get buyin from the um the
company to build a built-in integration,
they would just build a wrapper, their
own host application with their own
tools. And the thing is, users don't
want to do that. Users want one Jarvis,
just one, just one Jarvis that is able
to augment itself with any capability in
the world, any possible capability. They
don't want to have to load up your uh
LLM wrapper with the context necessary
and then grab that context and put it
into the next tool and whatever. They
want one thing that can interface with
all of them. And so, yeah, it can do
stuff, but it can't do enough. And that
is a big pain. And that's what pushes us
into phase three, MCP. Now with MCP, it
can do anything because MCP is a
standard protocol that all of the
different assistants support or will
very soon support. And uh now you can
build to the MCP spec and you're usable
by any of these AI assistants because
it's a standard. So we can do anything.
The clients aren't quite ready at the
time of this recording just yet, but
soon they will be and it's going to be
phenomenal. We are just one really good
user experience application away from
Jarvis for everybody and that's very
exciting. So to expand out on this a
little bit uh as far as the architecture
is concerned the host application is
communicating with the LLM and the host
application tells the LLM what services
are available to it and those services
can be dynamically added. Uh they uh can
be um added and removed. So like this
context can be managed by the host
application and the LLM just knows
what's available now and the user's
query and then it can select the most
appropriate tool. The host application
creates a client for every uh service
that it wants to integrate interface
with and this client is a standard uh
client. So it doesn't need to have any
special uh integration with anything.
There's a standard interface for this
and then the service provider creates
the MCP servers and uh those servers
interface with tools, resources,
prompts, sampling like lots of really uh
cool features on that end of the
spectrum. And this is what makes it so
great is that the service provider is in
control of this stuff. This is the stuff
that's going to be unique to every uh
service. uh everything else like the the
server and the client that interface
that communication is standard and
that's why this works. That's why it's
so cool. This is how uh the way I say it
is this is how we give Jarvis hands to
be able to actually do stuff. It's very
exciting. So I want to show you a little
demo of um a couple of MCP servers that
I put together uh to kind of explore
what's possible here. Like I said, the
clients aren't quite ready. So, the
experience is not the uh what the Jarvis
experience was, but I I don't see any
reason why we can't get there. So, let's
get into that. So, first, um I made this
uh in London, so it's going to find out
my current location here in a second,
but uh here's the prompt. This is in in
Cloud Desktop with which has been
configured with my MCP servers, three of
them. Please write a journal entry for
me. So, one of the MCP servers is a a
journaling uh server. Uh here's my email
address about my trip with my daughter.
I would like you to derive my location
and weather conditions from my device
location and make up a creative story
with relevant text. Thanks. So, we
execute this and as part of the context,
um it uh has an MCPP server called
locationator which will determine the
current location. And so, with this, I'm
going to allow it for this chat. Now,
you notice Tony didn't have to approve
different tool calls and stuff for
Jarvis because Tony has a lot of trust
built up with Jarvis. We don't quite
have that trust built up yet or that uh
capability and so that's why we're not
quite there yet. Um and we have to
approve every tool call and stuff, but
we'll get there eventually once uh
things get more reliable. So, here it
gets my current location. That was my
location at the London Hotel, so don't
worry, this isn't my home. Uh and then I
check the weather. This is from another
tool uh another server uh get weather
for getting the current weather at um uh
given uh coordinates. And now it's going
to run another tool from EpicMe. This is
the authenticate tool because I haven't
logged in yet. And so I'm going to
provide my email address to the EpicMe
server. And at the time of uh this demo
um I didn't want to actually open up my
email in uh as part of this recording.
And so um I was just running it locally
and I logged it to the uh console. So
let me just grab that token and I
provide that O token. And so now my MCP
client has been authent or it's going to
be authenticated with this validation
token. So the MCP server has
authentication built in. It's based on
OOTH 2.1. And so it's uh as secure as
anything else that you're using OOTH
with. And um my uh Jarvis client or or
cloud desktop has been authenticated so
I can perform authenticated tasks which
uh one of which is to create a journal
entry. Now of course the LLM is going to
write the journal entry for me. I didn't
want to take the time to do that but you
could write your own journal entry uh of
course and uh have it just insert that
yourself. And with the right kind of
interface you could uh speak your
journal entry and it could format it
nicely for you and everything. That's
what makes these LLMs so cool and
especially when we're talking about
multi multimodal stuff. So, um we're
going to create a journal entry um with
that information. U my MCP server
configured the inputs and things. And
now it's going to check, okay, what tags
do you have available? Okay, great. So,
you've got a travel tag. Uh let's or
let's create a travel tag because you
don't have one for that and that makes
sense for this journal entry. We'll add
that uh tag to the entry. And uh and
then like it continues uh in this
manner. And here's another really cool
and interesting thing about MCP in the
fact that it were working with an LLM.
Um is I I can actually ask it, hey,
could you show me that journal entry?
And remember that journal entry, it had
a title and it had contents. Um, but
here it's going to uh retrieve that
journal entry and then it decides based
off of what it retrieves that there's a
a good way to format that that's better
than just the JSON format that is
provided. So the server can communicate
in a way that makes a lot of sense for
the server. Um, and then the client can
take that as context to display whatever
it wants to the user. Right now we don't
have um very many uh clients that
support any mechanism for displaying
like a dynamic UI or like a card or or
something like that. But you can imagine
that we could totally do that. There's
nothing stopping us from doing that. And
I think it's actually also interesting
that it rendered this as kind of
markdown with a title and everything
too. Uh which I think is pretty cool.
And additionally uh I could actually ask
it to translate this into any language
and it would do a pretty good job of
that too. So maybe the MCP server is uh
sending responses in English, but you're
talking to your LLM in Japanese, and the
LLM can convert that English response
into Japanese, which I just think is
very very uh cool and interesting. So
here now, I'm telling it to delete the
post and log me out because it's fake.
And um again, all of the authentication
stuff that you would expect uh all works
here. The EpicMe MCP server is
completely only
accessible via uh MCP and uh clients
like this. You can't actually access it
as a web application. And I think that
is the transition that we're going to be
experiencing very soon. Users don't want
to use a browser. They don't want to
Google and have to figure out the right
way to phrase their question. When I was
teaching my parents how to Google, uh
they just typed out a full-on question
and their results were not very good.
So, we had to train them. No, no, no.
You have to write it in this special
format and then you'll find like with
these keywords and stuff and then you'll
find what you're looking for. Well, now
we're going back to what's more natural.
Just speak your question and the AI will
be able to figure out what you're trying
to accomplish and not just what you're
trying to search for, but what you're
actually trying to do. And it'll
actually be able to do that thing for
you. That is what MCP enables and that's
why I'm so excited about it. So just to
wrap us up, I've got a bunch of
resources for you. There's the
specification for model context
protocol. It's very good. You should
definitely take a look at that. I am
very active on EpicAI. And so you can go
check out
epicai.pro and learn all about not just
MCP, but AI in general. I've got a whole
bunch of uh posts that you can take a
look at uh all about um the the future
of user interaction and how AI is
changing the game for us. It's very
exciting and I hope that you join me
there. I also have workshops and cohorts
and things that you can go through uh
join me on and the the at whatever time
you're watching this there will be uh
something to to go and learn there. So
go check out epicai.pro. With that, I
just want to say you're great. Thank you
so much for watching my talk.